The term "cult classic" gets tossed around
a little too much, but is it really always
justified?
On occasion, a movie is so poorly made that
it finds its way into the "cult classic" conversation
by way of the "so bad it's great" loophole.
More often than not, "so bad" just means they're
actually terrible films, kinda like the ones
on this list.
Children Of The Corn
Adapted from Stephen King’s short story,
Children Of The Corn takes place in an isolated
Nebraska town and follows a child-led religious
cult, hell bent on ensuring that the town's
corn crop remains robust.
Of course, they have to sacrifice all of the
adults to make that happen.
That last bit bodes poorly for an out-of-town
couple driving through their fields.
“We must sacrifice them both tonight.”
“Amos will satisfy him.
We need the woman, she’ll bring the man
to us.”
“No...”
So what went wrong with Children of the Corn?
King tried to adapt it for the big screen
himself, but the author's moody, character-driven
screenplay was tossed aside in favor of George
Goldsmith's ludicrous, hyper-violent, narratively
flimsy take on the tale.
Even if some of the film's imagery still colors
the pop-culture landscape, Children of the
Corn is a stagnant and ugly film to look at,
leading us to question just how this film
managed to inspire its own straight-to-video
franchise.
Grandma's Boy
There's no accounting for taste when you're
talking about cult classics.
Still, every once in a while, a film claims
cult status that just makes you want to hold
people accountable.
Case in point: 2006's stoner comedy Grandma's
Boy.
Understand that we're using the word "comedy"
loosely here, because there's really not much
to laugh at in this tale of a 35-year-old
slacker forced to move in with his Grandma.
Realistically, there are only about four actual
jokes in Grandma's Boy, and the film simply
recycles them over and over and over again.
“What’s in here?”
“That’s just the kids in the their break
room, or as I call it the stupid idiot room.”
We get it, they smoke a lot of pot, play a
lot of video games, and that one guy acts
like a robot.
What else you got?
The answer is a resounding "Nothing."
The Room
In 2003 Tommy Wiseau unleashed The Room on
the world, and almost in spite of itself,
it's become a bonafide cult sensation over
the years.
James Franco even took on the feature-length
re-enactment of what went on behind the scenes
with The Disaster Artist.
We can't help but be a little worried that
people are taking Wiseau's disasterpiece seriously.
Wiseau's tale of a good man losing it all
looks and feels like a no-budget TV show from
the early 90s, the dialogue is often unintelligible,
and the acting is embarrassingly over the
top.
“I did not hit her.
It’s not true.
It’s bulls---.
I did not hit her.
I did not.
Oh, hi Mark.”
To make matters worse, it doesn't look like
any of the cast, save for Wiseau, has a clue
what's going to happen from one moment to
the next.
We get it, everyone loves to watch a disaster,
but that doesn't mean the disaster deserves
to be celebrated.
Showgirls
So you've got a friend who read a book that
says Paul Verhoeven's 1995 sexploitation satire
Showgirls is a misunderstood masterpiece?
“Nomi, what kind of turn was that?
Do a pique turn.
That’s it.”
With all due respect to your “friend,”
here are three irrefutable facts that prove
just how bad Showgirls is.
One: Kyle Maclachlan is still shocked by just
how bad it turned out.
In a 2012 interview he admitted to being "gobsmacked"
after seeing it.
Two: Elizabeth Berkley, a trained dancer in
real life, gave up dancing for years after
the film's release.
Three: Showgirls basically ended the career
of Berkley, as well as screenwriter Joe Eszterhas,
who was one of Hollywood's hottest writers
at the time.
Although one could argue Verhoeven was brilliant
to exploit the script's ridiculous plot and
misguided sense of feminism, its record-setting
run at the 1995 Razzie Awards proves our point.
Dune
There's not a filmmaker on this list with
more cult-cred than David Lynch, but even
the famed auteur couldn't "cult" his way into
bringing a successful version of Frank Herbert's
sci-fi novel Dune to the big screen.
Lynch's big-budget debut hit theaters in 1984
and was immediately marked as an epic misfire
by critics.
In his one-star review of the film, Roger
Ebert stated,
"This movie is a real mess....One of the most
confusing screenplays of all time."
If you've sat through all two hours and 20
minutes of the film yourself, you know it's
true.
Though Lynch shoulders much of the blame,
he's not entirely at fault.
Dune was, after all, just his third feature
film as director.
After small-scale successes with Eraserhead
and The Elephant Man, Dune was a dramatic
shift in both scale and story for Lynch.
Maybe a little too big.
Matters only got worse in post-production
when financiers wrestled control of Dune away
from Lynch.
The result was an absolute mess of a film.
The sort of mess that makes us wonder whether
its "cult classic" status isn't merely a reflection
on the man who directed it.
Mommie Dearest
Even if you haven't seen bizarro 1981 melodrama
Mommie Dearest, you can almost certainly quote
its most famous line.
“No wire hangers!”
Please trust us when we advise you to leave
your exposure to Mommie Dearest to that singular
moment because the rest of the film only gets
weirder, and not in a good way.
Part soap opera drama and part psychological
horror film, Mommie Dearest takes its story
from a memoir penned by Joan Crawford's adopted
daughter Christina.
At the center of it all is a performance from
Faye Dunaway that can only be described as
really, really big; so big it ends up dwarfing
the work of everyone she shared the screen
with.
It's the sort of performance that most directors
would beg an actor to tone down.
Unfortunately, Mommie Dearest director Frank
Perry let Dunaway run with it, and she ran
his film right into the realm of caustic,
unwatchable camp.
Howard The Duck
Howard The Duck was destined to claim "cult
classic" status before cameras even rolled,
mostly because the Marvel comic that spawned
it was the very definition of cult fiction.
At the center of that comic was a wise-cracking,
cigar-chomping, kung-fu-fighting fowl who
goes by the name of Howard.
“Fly away!”
“Shoo!”
“No one laughs at a Master of quack-foo.”
Yes, Howard The Duck is every bit as bonkers
as it sounds.
It was produced as a live-action feature even
though director William Huyck believed it
would work better as animation.
The film's producer George Lucas was the one
who insisted that the project go ahead with
bold, practical effects and, um, a dwarf in
a duck suit.
We're pretty sure Lucas regretted that decision
once Howard The Duck was finished.
The seemingly ready-made "cult classic" proved
an absolute eye-sore of a film.